I want to talk to about
how I learned Japanese.
This is Steve Kaufman again, if you
enjoy my videos, please subscribe,
click on the bell for notifications.
So, you know, how did it come
about that I learned Japanese?
Japanese ended up being very
influential in my life, my social
life, my professional career.
Uh, and yet, you know, back in 1968, I
was sent to Hong Kong by the Canadian
government to learn Mandarin Chinese.
So I, how did I end up with Japanese
being such a dominant language in my life?
So I thought I'd go over that and go over
with you some of the sort of things that
helped me learn Japanese and more than
any book or anything as I sort of reflect
back on it now, it was my attitude.
Uh, and of course the amount
of time that I was prepared
to spend on learning Japanese.
So 68, I go to Hong Kong.
I spent a year learning Chinese.
Um, and then the idea was that I would
be working in the, uh, Canadian High
Commission in Hong Kong using my Chinese.
Unfortunately there developed
a sort of a conflict of,
personality conflict or whatever, with
my immediate boss at the High Commission.
And the idea was that, uh, Canada would
open up a, an embassy in Beijing and
I would be working for this person.
Uh, it would be a very isolated posting.
He and I didn't get along.
So I announced to the Canadian
Trade Commissioner Service that I
refused to go to Beijing to work
under this person in an
isolated post, life would be
hell for two and a half years.
I said on the other hand, since the
government had paid for me, essentially
to learn Chinese, which I had done in,
in, uh, you know, quick time in a year,
whereas normally two years was sort
of the allotted time to learn Chinese.
I said, I will, if you assign me to
Japan, I will learn Japanese on my own.
Won't cost you a penny and you
will have at least gotten some
return on your investment.
Looking back on it is, is kind of,
um, almost a foolhardy thing for me to
do, but I was not to go and spend two
years in an isolated post with someone
with whom I had very strong personality
conflicts and in their wisdom the
Trade Commissioner Service agreed.
So I then started buying books
in Hong Kong on Japanese.
And, uh, I still remember that one of the
first things I learned was, uh, how does,
how you, how you say, "how do you do?"
When you meet someone for the first time.
And the expression was ... I
learned that I sort of memorized it.
I have never used that expression.
Nobody uses, nobody uses that expression,
a completely useless expression.
It's an indication that much of
what you get in beginner books
may not be all that useful.
You have to be prepared to...
you don't necessarily eliminate
it, but you learn it and forget it.
And you don't worry about it.
Anything that's thrown at me
at any stage in my learning.
It's not really important to me,
whether I am able to hang on to it.
In time, I'll figure it out,
whether I need it or whether, I
don't know, in the case of ... not
something that I ever needed.
So while in Hong Kong, because I had
friends amongst the various other
diplomats who were studying Chinese,
I had very good friends amongst the,
uh, people at the Japanese consulate,
and one of those people
was very fluent in Chinese.
And, uh, he wanted to learn English.
So we would meet for lunch
twice a week at a very famous,
uh, dim sum place in Hong Kong.
The, uh, ... Hotel and, uh,
Tuesday we would speak English and
Thursday we would speak Japanese.
I don't know what I was able to
say, whatever I was able to find
in my book, I would try it out.
It wasn't much of a conversation.
But it was part of starting
to experience things Japanese.
So then in, uh, I guess January of
'71, we moved to Japan and I went to
a school right under the Tokyo tower
called the ..., uh, ... Japanese school.
Nitoguri Sensei was a
very charismatic man.
And his message was ... heart to heart.
And we would sit around in this classroom,
five or six of us, and we would all
try to mumble something in Japanese.
And I did that for a month.
And then I realized that this
was largely a waste of my time.
So I quit that.
And I started doing a lot of reading.
I let a, I read a lot in, in this
series by Naganuma, which I've
mentioned before, which is all Hiragana.
Because since I had the characters from
Chinese, I had to get used to the kanna,
and even though compared to Chinese
characters, Hiragana is easy to learn,
there's only whatever it is, 50 symbols.
Never underestimate how difficult it
is to get used to a new writing system,
even though theoretically, you know
what the symbols represent, before
your brain gets used to absorbing, you
know, messages, information with that
writing system takes a long, long time.
So I read lots and I listened to lots
and continued to scour the bookstores
for reading material, wherever possible
with cassette tapes, much more difficult
at that time to find such material,
but whatever I could find I consumed.
I was lucky enough that, uh, at the
Canadian Embassy where I was working, I
had an assistant commercial, uh, officer,
as they were known, these sort of locally
engaged staff who worked with the trade
commissioners, who had the contacts,
who would accompany you to visits.
And his name was Nick Yazaki and he was extremely
long-winded, and extremely patient and
he would speak to me and he would say
everything four or five times, and I would
listen to him and I would imitate his,
the way he droned on and repeated things.
But when you're learning a language,
if you are lucky enough to have
someone to talk to who is, uh,
you know, long of wind and repeats
things, that's extremely helpful.
And with Nick, we would go and
visit, uh, you know, potential,
uh, you know, contacts, people who
wanted to buy Canadian products.
Uh, first two years I was promoting
food products in the second two years
of the four years, I was promoting
forest products and we would visit
with Japanese contacts and, um, I
would kind of hang in there, but,
you know, and I try to say something
and I pretend that I understood it.
And I think this was the
other attitude that I had.
It never bothered me that I,
for the longest time, didn't
understand a hundred percent.
I understand 30%, 40%, 50%, but I'd
be in there nodding part of the deal
after the meeting, I'd asked Nick,
like, what exactly did they say?
I, maybe I said something
that was totally irrelevant.
It never really bothered me.
Uh, I was in a Japanese environment.
I was being exposed to the language
I was picking up on things.
And, but it does take a long time.
And I can remember that even after years
of living in Japan, the only television
programs that I could understand where
baseball and Sumo, because there's,
you know, the dialogue is relatively
limited, uh, you seeing what's happening.
And so that was kind
of what I would watch.
It took me a long time before I could
understand, you know, uh, drama, you
know, soap operas or sword movies or
slash movies or any of that stuff.
Uh, it just takes a long
time, but I was in a hurry.
I certainly didn't want to
write any exam in Japanese.
I just wanted to use it to the
extent that I could use it.
And, and where my Japanese really took
off was when I, uh, left the embassy
and I started working on my own.
So now I didn't have a Nick Yazaki.
I had to basically, you know, handle
these relationships by myself.
And, uh, there were times and I had
Japanese people working with me and
we'd be in the car, driving around
the countryside for hours in traffic.
And just talking, talking, talking,
talking about lumber, talking about,
and of course the Japanese way
of business is quite fascinating.
And I had to learn about how they cut
the trees, the logs, and how they cut
for different grade for different grain,
for different qualities, the different,
uh, you know, idiosyncrasies of wood
that they didn't like or did like.
And we could talk forever about wood.
Mostly we just talked about wood, but
we talked for hours and I also had
a customer, but we didn't only talk
wood, I had a customer when I was
working for a major, again, Canadian
forest products, export company.
I had a customer in Nagoya.
We were also selling newsprint and the
Chunichi Shimbun in Nagoya, which is the
major newsprint...newspaper in Nagoya,
and they had a purchasing manager and
I had to go and be nice to him so that
they would continue buying our paper.
And I would go down there once a
month and yeah, and we would sit
in a Japanese restaurant and sit on
the floor and, uh, consume a bottle
of whiskey and discuss philosophy.
So I had to be up on subjects
related to philosophy.
We didn't talk about the price
of newpaper, we didn't talk about
anything related to business.
We talked about philosophy,
which was a lot of fun.
And, uh, I mean, I can't remember
all the different things, but my,
my basic attitude was one of just,
you know, roll with the punches.
Um, and I would go in and find
readers with glossaries and, and for
the longest time, when I saw Chinese
character, I would pronounce it
to myself in Chinese.
And um very often not know how
that was pronounced in Japanese.
I, there were like, I would hear it
and I knew what it meant, but I didn't
necessarily relate that character
to any particular pronunciation.
So I would read in Hiragana
and pronounce it in Chinese,
continue reading in Hiragana,
and acquire this vocabulary.
Now this has all been, become
much easier today because, because
we have text to speech, we can
look up words in dictionaries.
We can, uh, we have, like at
LingQ we have furigana, the little
guys on top of the character.
So much easier.
It's unbelievably much easier,
even though, you know, ta LingQ
it's not perfect because the
word-splitting algorithm doesn't
quite work as well as we would like.
And we're looking at ways to
make it better, but it's still
so much easier to learn today
than it was back in those days.
So, uh, and, and I should say amongst the
various sources that I would listen to,
and I got into my car and Tokyo in August
when it was like 36 degrees and the sun
has been beating down on my car and I get
in there and the steering wheel is just
like, scalding hot then I would put on
my ... the history of the Shōwa era, which
I must have listened to 20, 30 times.
So it's all I think my immersion in
Japanese was one of, I wanted to explore,
I wanted to experience the language.
I'd say what I thought I was able
to say, sometimes get it wrong.
It didn't bother me.
I listened to what
people were saying to me.
And basically relied on my
brain to gradually start saying
more and more things correctly.
I never really focused in on the grammar,
grammar rules, rules about when to
use which polite form, none of that.
I just basically allowed the language to
come to me and trusted that my brain would
pick up on the patterns of the language.
And today my Japanese is,
as it is, it's not perfect.
Uh, I don't, I haven't tried to zoom
in on any particular aspects of either
polite language or pitch accent or any
of these other things I communicate.
I understand.
I'm happy.
It serves my purposes.
And I think people, uh, are
quite comfortable communicating
with me in Japanese.
And you can watch two of my videos in
Japanese here, just to give you a bit
of the flavor of my Japanese as it is
right now, which reminds me, I just
wanted to say one more thing, learning
other languages and having an absence
from Japanese has improved my Japanese.
In other words, the fact of learning
other languages and particularly the
10 languages I've learned since the age
of 60, including Russian and including,
you know, Korean, Ukrainian, and now
struggling with Arabic and Persian.
All of that is good for the brain
and actually improves my Japanese.
Although if I haven't spoken it for
awhile, I'm initially quite rusty,
but then ultimately I become better.
So there you have it, uh, a brief
discussion about how I learned Japanese.
I hope that's helpful.